the jurgen experience so how are you
catching fish you you brought a
a rod yeah i caught most of them this is
a birch pole i'd rigged up a little
thing that made me so i could cast and i
could
cast a long ways out and it was the
funnest fishing i've ever done you could
cast
yeah made with like a spool that i had
brought for my
fishing line or whatever and what did
you use for like the eyes
for the the uh wire a snare wire was one
of the things i brought
so i'd made like rigged up a little
fishing pole and it worked great it was
real similar to what they use in
soviet like old soviet reels so i had
been
gave me the idea for making that style
of it real because they're just so basic
you know and it takes a little practice
to use but anyway
i rigged it up it worked great i could
cast way out there
it took me a long time to catch my first
fish a few weeks but after i did i kind
of like dialed them in and it was
using bait or i made a lure like a
little spinner i made and that
and i caught a fish but it snapped my
line but the uh
and then i tried moose meat and they
loved it so
i would just be casting in on catching
them all on moose meat or like fish
belly you know you catch a
fish and cut out a strip a strip and
they loved that and it was
mostly lake trout but some of them were
you know over 20 pounds and you got this
homemade rod and you're like reeling it
in shaking your hands out
20 pound lake trout that's insane
with a homemade lure and a homemade
woody
trainer that's a different thing that's
paracord i was i was uh
yeah just testing out making like a fly
line out of paracord there
and did you have a leader as well like
using the paracord and like braiding it
down that's not
that's not the thing i used on the show
that was just experimenting
now when you were using the line what
kind of lot did you bring fishing yeah
that was another item i brought braided
yeah no you could only bring
monofilament and barbless hooks so it
made everything
that much more intense yeah why don't
why barbecue it's canadian
regulations or something yeah
silly people there was never going to be
any release in that situation
that's why it's so confusing yeah
but but they allowed you to what pound
test did you use 20
oh wow so you're like at the limit yeah
yeah and you got no drag so you're just
kind of
going on field yeah it was very wow
there you try to
drag it out like a fly rod where you let
it slip
away reel it in let it pull away until
it finally wears itself out which you
know it takes stripping the line in or
you
do you have something my little reel so
i could like put my thumb
on it on my spool and it would like drag
and drag and then i could reel it did
you reel with a finger
yeah oh wow i made like when it was cold
i made this rabbit fur glove that where
just the tip of my finger stuck out
and then uh yeah i gotta say that so how
many fish did you end up catching
there's 13 but they're all big you know
like they're all so you can eat them for
a couple days
yeah like from between probably eight
and twenty something pounds did you eat
the fish guts at all
did you uh yeah like i eat the stomachs
and uh
the head was the best part like when
you're out there you know starving and
you need fat it's like you almo a lot of
times i would eat the fish
and kind of put the main meat part of it
away for later but you need the belly
the head
like a soup with the head yeah i made
all my fish into
soup and then i would fry all my moose
basically oh no okay
all your fish you made it into something
yeah just to get all the nutrients out
of the
boat did you find any editable
vegetables or anything lots of berries
like up north
so it's awesome as far as berries go
although my spot didn't really have many
but i found patches you know like
well when you find berries you find
bears yeah yeah